ce sont des taches lumineuses sur des
photos satellites au moins quatorze
navires de la marine russe qui approche
à une cinquantaine de kilomètres
d'odessa sur la mer noire
invisible encore depuis la côte mais à
ce poste de surveillance improvisé au
bord de la plage mines et les militaires
d'ukrainiens savent qu'il s'agit de
navires de déchargement de troubles et
de chars de navire d'assaut amphibie
deux lanceurs de missiles
en accentue notre surveillance on
enregistre tous les mouvements à
l'horizon on a vu aujourd'hui quelques
bateaux russes de reconnaissance on sait
où ils sont ils ne peuvent pas nous
prendre par surprise
les forces russes s'apprêtait à lancer
un assaut maritime sur ce port
stratégique de la mer noire
sur l'une des plages du centre les
volontaires accélère la construction de
trancher
[Musique]
chantent l'hymne ukrainien pour
affronter leurs ennemis qui approche
on va les faire couler ils serviront de
nourriture aux poissons lui
chacun à son niveau accentue ses efforts
pour la défense territoriale ce
garagiste fin connaisseur de la façon
dont crever les pneus des véhicules
fabrique des herses à la chaîne peut se
déplier sur une largeur de 10 mètres
donc on peut bloquer le peu ligne de
véhicules
mais pour beaucoup cette menace russe
persistante et les nuits d'incertitude
deviennent insupportables à la gare les
trains se remplissent direction le
vivent depuis l'étranger
on est venu se réfugier à au dessin pas
se confier les bombes amis collègues
et maintenant il ya tous ces bateaux à
odessa
et nos mains tremblent notre coeur bat
on a peur c'est un cauchemar voir ces
bateaux c'est un choc
pour les autorités locales pas de doute
cet assaut maritime n'est plus qu'une
question de jours voire d'heures
désormais à chaque fois que la sirène
retentit dans les rues d'odessa les
habitants se demandent si cette attaque
tant redouté a commencé